chose promise chose due je vous
l'annoncé il ya un instant invités
l'antenne de midi madame cyd charisse à
propos de l'hommage qui lui est rendu
par paris notamment au théâtre du rond
point avec un spectacle qui se déroulera
le 25 juin je pense nous allons en
discuter
tout à l'heure madame site charice il
est inutile de vous la présenter si vous
aimez le cinéma et surtout la comédie
musicale je citerai quelques titres dans
lesquels elle a fait de grandes
performances hic fait folie 44-45 de
vicente minelli puisque c'était la star
chéri de vicente minnelli ce fut plus
tard chantons sous la pluie en 1952 de
john kelly et stanley donen et puis ce
fut aussi on enverra un extrait tout à
l'heure party girl de nicholas ray en
1958 sont que les titres les plus connus
madame vous comprenez français mais vous
ne parlez pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous allons demander à la
france un petit de traduire mes
questions la première une question est
anecdotique
je sais que si ce n'est pas votre vrai
prénom et qu'il qu'il est venu de votre
petit frère je crois sincèrement que je
suis très jeune
mon frère m'a y paraît comme ici en
belgique en apprenant ce système henning
restait à se faire vous appelez donc
vous appelez site parce qu'il n'arrivait
pas à dire 6 tel aviv difficultés pour
prononcer entièrement le le dentiste
heures alors plus tard quand je ne te
reconnais un studio peu fêlé cinéma à
free le plan plus de 7 de tri cette mise
car il le dit c'est pas possible
s est dit en anglais parce que c'est un
peu le cas sont alors et échangeaient 6
watts d'ici le fusil alors 7e jeu si
j'arrêtais pas vous introduire vous
parlait très bien français
alors françois va voir un extrait de
deux parties guerre mais si de charice
participe à un grand spectacle ce soir
d'abord il ya un hommage qui lui est
rendu par un certain nombre de gens
comme nicole croisille jean pierre
aumont
on montre ses films et puis il va y
avoir au théâtre du rond point toute une
série qui s'appelle de broadway à
hollywood avec sur scène des spectacles
de comédies musicales avec des musiques
de colporteurs de gershwin 42e rue west
side story
chantons sous la pluie avec également
des récitals de barbe
à cooke et des projections de films et
puis party girl sort également dans une
salle parisienne
alors madame chéri vous avez beaucoup
dansé avec fred astaire et gene kelly
kelly sur lui qualité le partenaire que
vous préfériez un tout l'été c'est ma
vie c'est pas possible dit il c'est
mieux que l'autre possède tout à fait
différent far east est ravie de vous
c'est une incomparable et danseuses qui
bouge et se déplacent magnifiquement
elle vous que dites vous de frais rester
à et la même chose les spéciales mais
les spécialistes et avoir une ligne afin
de la faire il n'y en aura jamais
d'autre
votre formation c'était la danse
classique le palace thématique à la
danse et vous aviez pris un pseudonyme
qui avait une consonance russe pour
faire peut-être plus dans cette
classique non samaria estime ana maria
uteau mena les lignes woods elin woods a
calé cette souris vous avez été une
grande interprète de vicente minelli on
dit que vous êtes jeu facile on le dit
parce que c'est vrai vous êtes sa sa
star chéri est ce que c'est le
réalisateur qui visent à le plus fasciné
dans la manière de mettre en scène
l'image et la danse vincente minnelli
fascine et du special et oui mais c'est
balma fait mais les robes sexy 4s est
l'homme de glace à rome et vous avez
avait travaillé avec marilyn monroe qui
n'avait pas terminé ce film c'était en
1962 un film de john george cukor
quelque chose doit finir par craquer
quel est le souvenir que vous avez deux
marines maintenant elle est elle est
très gentille fille la veille ce qui
aura elle ne devait pas elle se sentait
pas en sécurité
l'allergie à famille du pn sécuritaire
elle avait demandé que si tu charries
soit dans le film avec elle elle est née
chez le père était un film très charmant
s'il avait pu être terminé d'ailleurs il
a été terminée mais avec une autre
distribution alors france nous regardons
un extrait de de party girl de nicholas
ray parce qu'il ya beaucoup envie de
voir danser et j'aime balle est très
célèbre où elle danse avec une robe avec
une traîne même en dansant ne pourrait
pas s'arranger avec cette prennent elles
n'y arrivent mais vous regardons madame
mais
ah les yeux de robert taylor vous êtes
vous êtes venu avec votre mari tony
martin qui va chanter pour vous qu'est
ce tu es sexy aux lettres et langues
fallait voter elle a été mariée avec lui
alors il ya beaucoup de leur mariage à
hollywood
par exemple j me soit le divorce entre
la tristesse
merci madame charih êtes revenus en 2010
je voudrais vous parler de ce livre qui
s'intitule aussi site charice de
jean-claude mission aux éditions henry
dérailler c'est un excellent livre avec
de très bonnes illustrations qui vous
remettra ont en souvenir les plus grands
moments de la comédie musicale au cinéma
américain